pete davidson has a new show with lauren
michaels it's going to be all about his
kind of like a hyper reality of himself
what do you think about that
i think he's a very interesting self as
selfs go i made a poor choice last week
this is my boy kevin
[Music]
you have any questions that is me i'm
looking forward to it i've always
enjoyed everything pete's done he's done
a fantastic job of being very honest
about himself on snl and i think that's
why people have been really connected to
i mean really really you want to go back
and co-host
no i'm too old
come on nah i feel like when i went back
there to host i felt like an athlete who
lost like 10 miles off his fastball i
mean i'm so impressed
with everybody who's still doing it it
was the best
but
it was a young man's game once you hit
my age once you have kids
i'm not cut out for it anymore seth is
actually leaning hard into dad life he
just wrote his first kids book out now
entitled i'm not scared you're scared i
mean when you're a dad and you have
young children you read a lot of
children's a lot about that what
inspired you it's amazing how many of
them are the same ones you read when you
were a kid which speaks to the fact
that it's a kind of writing
where if you get it right it's going to
stick around for a long time so you were
financially motivated because it would
stick around forever i mean your kids
would
look everything i do with my children is
financially motivated and i tell them
that before bed every night what was the
inspiration behind the book i just think
you have kids and you start thinking
about the idea of fear a lot more both
your own and theirs
and so i wanted to write a book that was
both an adventure story that kids would
be engaged in with characters that
they'd like to hear about but also maybe
start a conversation between parents and
their kids about why it's okay to be
afraid of things i was dropping my son
off at school today and was talking to
another parent and turned around and my
son was gone and the teacher said no he
went in he was just bored waiting for
you uh did not say goodbye so he went in
and yet at the same time i was standing
there saying you were sure he went in
you were like yes
because that's the kind of fear you have
yeah you just are scared all the time
this is bear
he's scared of everything
which one of your celebrity guests or
friends would be your bear john goodman
i mean if this is the voice of the bear
it's john goodman just like everything
about the voice the bear voice yeah as
far as my most fraidy cat friend i mean
it's probably
me or sandberg we're the fraidy cats dan
burke really yeah huge pretty cat
[Music]
how's your youngest
she's great i mean she's just it's like
she knows we have two
older sons and she's given us a break
before she starts being a nightmare but
she has just been
the most wonderful little nugget i'm in
charge of the boys a little bit more
than i was
and sometimes i'll walk by this little
girl and we'll look at each other like
we should do something one of these days
we should get a coffee
i would love to we'd love to hear what
you're about
[Music]